in the shadow of flight paths on the
perimeter of airports just some of the
places where you'll find workers for
whom life just got that little bit more
uncertain
miguel is one of them he works for a
handling firm at heathrow he's been on
either furlough or flexi furlough for
the entire pandemic although his job has
survived his hours and pay have been
significantly cut back it's been very
strange the fact of in the beginning
being paid to be at home in the
beginning it may sound like a
dream idea for some people but in my
case i i love my job
the stress of knowing whether there will
be jobs available or not has been always
the main
worry
for many here that uncertainty will feel
familiar 1.6 million people were still
on furlough this summer it's unclear how
many of those jobs will survive
sky news analysis has found that there
are 18 local authorities with over eight
percent of people still on furlough as
of mid-august
of these 11 are also in the top 10
percent of areas with the highest
universal credit claimants
one of them is here in hounslow west
london
it has the highest furlough rate in the
country and the fifth highest claimant
count
at the hope church there's a sense
they're bracing an already squeezed
community they say now faces a spiraling
cost of living and no safety net
there's a lot of low paid
labor here so um it's it's been really
hard for them to
find other jobs that will pay enough for
them to be able to live and the furlough
scheme has helped
but it's only gone so far
the fellow scheme in particular was
unprecedented and it's no doubt saved
millions of jobs in tens of thousands of
companies and has kept unemployment
relatively low but the impacts will be
felt for a long time in communities like
this in terms of the cost tens of
billions of pounds that will need to be
paid back probably through higher taxes
or lower spending
and for some it's already too late
claire is a single mum and was
furloughed from her job as a travel
agent but she was ultimately let go and
relies on the now reduced universal
credit
all of a sudden you have to cut things
short and just say
no i need to do this i need to stop that
i can't have this luxury this month you
don't mean having to tell your kids that
they can't get something because you've
no money is ridiculous
the government never said it could or
should save every job and it certainly
saved many
but for some emerging from a
transformative scheme into a transformed
economy they still face a winter packed
with problems
helen and smith sky news in hanslow